I made the gargantuan mistake of seeing
this film on an empty stomach
[Music]
chef is written by directed by and
starring Jon Favreau as well as Sofia
Vergara John Leguizamo Robert Downey
junior Scarlett Johansson Oliver Platt
all of these really great people are in
this film it's really actually a
fantastic cast one of the better cast of
the year what this film is about is a
chef played by Jon Favreau and he's in
the middle of a bit of a struggle
because he works for a great restaurant
he's kind of under the illusion that he
can make whatever he wants but Dustin
Hoffman who plays the store owner has
more of a hold on him that he wishes
because of various things he decides you
know what this isn't for me I'm gonna
start a food truck I'm gonna travel
around the world and make awesome food
for people and he takes his son along
with him and then attempt to bond with
him what we get is a great feel-good
comedy and food do you like food of
course you like food why am I even
asking this do not see this movie if you
have not eaten beforehand because this
movie is food porn food looks incredible
in this movie the things that are
prepared the things that people eat as
soon as this movie ended my fiance and I
went to a restaurant the closest
restaurant we could find and we just ate
food because we were just like we need
to eat food right now and I gotta get
props my fiancee because I wasn't
actually gonna see this movie but she's
like you don't want to see a movie today
hey what about this movie chef that's
playing nearby and I was like chef I
forgot all about chef I wanted to talk
about it I wanted to review it and I
completely forgot it in the mix of all
the blockbusters that have been coming
out lately and I feel bad that I didn't
review it when I had the opportunity to
a couple weeks ago because this is a
really good movie it's a movie that not
only is a lot of fun for me to watch
because I do have an interest in cooking
I do have an interest in food I've
always liked to cook my fiance likes to
cook my parents like to cook we like to
cook and it's really cool to watch
people who really know what they're
doing in a kitchen and this movie has a
really awesome way of making you feel as
if you're in that kitchen showing you
what it's like to go to different places
on this food truck to experience
different cultures the music the sights
the sounds and of course the food
one of the greatest things about this
movie is that the human characters
behind all of that seems so real
Jon Favreau did an excellent job at
capturing characters and dialogue in
situations and scenes that did not feel
set up they didn't feel faked the
dialogue and this movie flows and it
feels so improvisational at times that
you really feel almost like you're
watching a documentary the relationship
between Jon Favreau and his young son
who by the way gives a very good
performance in this movie was very sweet
and very endearing did not feel sappy or
forced I had this theory that almost
anything that a movie could be about can
be good if you have characters doing
this thing that are interesting
characters that seem relatable that you
actually care about that you want to see
succeed you know and in this film you
have that also Jon Favreau when this
movie really surprised me as an actor
this is by far in my opinion his best
performance he's got layers in this
movie sorry for that horrible imitation
of Christopher Walken but in all honesty
he really was great in this movie and he
did such a great job balancing all the
duties he had in this film and I got to
say John Leguizamo who I have kind of
given some beef in the past you know
he's not always my favorite part of
movies he was very good in this movie
and his character definitely added a lot
of good comedy to the film despite not
having a huge role Dustin Hoffman did a
very good job with the scenes that he
was in there are definitely parts this
movie you can tell that Jon Favreau
knows people involved in Marvel and the
Avengers because he's got Scarlett
Johansson and Robert Downey jr. in brief
roles but also kind of added to one of
my problems with the movie it was very
entertaining to see them on-screen but I
didn't really feel like their characters
had much of an arc or really any real
importance in the movie Downey jr. is in
one scene and he did great in that
scenes I'm not really as concerned about
that but Scarlett Johansson actually has
a fairly large part in the first and
second act of this film but I didn't
really feel like her character had an
arc to her and I was kind of wondering
what happened with her as a feel-good
comedy this is one of the best I've seen
in a while and it's so cool to see these
guys make this awesome food that just
makes your mouth water I'm gonna give
chef and a - I really do think it is a
very good feel-good comedy one of the
best I've seen in a while and especially
one of the better films revolving around
cooks that I've seen in a long time I
would suggest checking out chef if it's
playing in a theater near you but do not
see it on and
stomach be sure to not make the same
mistake I did because you're gonna be
drooling the entire time guys thank you
so much for watching if you saw the film
I'm interested in knowing what you
thought and as always if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
when eyes
[Music]